One of the things that I think is
depressed me most about our political
system in the last decade or so has been
the incredible partisanship.
There's nothing wrong with people
fighting about issues and having
different views about them and arguing
vigorously for that point of view,
but opposing a point of view simply
because it's the point of view of the
other party,
right?
That's bad.
We hold these truths to be self evident.
All men are created equal.
I think you're going down by their
creator,
certain money
leaving their America and they have a
lot of money.
That was on my values.
Moral values.
We don't have to do anything but look
right there and so yeah,
for tomorrow's have dropped in this
country,
dewey,
you can actually see Russia from land
here in Alaska.
You cannot go to a seven 11 or a Dunkin
donuts unless you have a slight Indian
accent.
We're headed towards 2030 years of
incredible chaos and turmoil.
Yeah.
On Iraq,
on the economy,
on healthcare,
on a global warming.
There's no real issue where the parties
are grieving and the distinctions are
huge.
These are the people that are connected
with the Barack Obama
needs to return to Illinois and the
Senate and get some experience and get
out and live in the real world for a few
years and get out of that elitist
conclave.
They called Barack Obama and elitist and
they pretended to Republicans on their
assigned sending mckeen.
Her heart warming story when she was a
kid is she helped her dad pick out a
several hundred thousand dollars
fountain in front of their mansion.
John Mccain spurned one establishment,
but ended up ironically embracing the
other,
which is the cultural conservatives.
No question about it.
I think the Republican Party understands
better what's in the Bible than the
Democratic Party.
They demonstrate it.
Metro.
Yes.
There's no reason to kill an unborn
baby.
God wouldn't want that.
Republicans wouldn't want that.
And Democrats want that.
Um,
it seems like it is
John Mccain.
Like he's a real guy.
You know,
he's had a real life.
Don't think he eats a ruble.
I seen him do hot dogs and hamburgers.
This is the Huffington Post,
always as loud.
This is a chocolate smoothie buddy.
Healthy chocolate got so I know any raw,
organic,
fair trade,
Cacao powder,
everything that's happening out in the
world today is happening because there's
a sense of it's us against them.
This sense of other myths.
You guys under our tech and you're
responding with kindness.
It doesn't work.
I mean,
you were in the heat of a battle to win
this race.
A bubble.
Obama needs a sword and a shield.
The Shield,
which is secondary,
is to fend off with vigor and strength
the attacks,
but the most important thing is the sore
stand up,
stand up.
Merck is based on ideas.
We have enough intelligence.
No to remove radical poverty in all
parts of the world.
Or the trick for the future is to find
ways to recreate what used to be called
the vital center.
One question that I think it's always
useful to ask is,
if I am so sure I'm right,
how come she social?
She's right too.
There's always the possibility to make
change.
Good
big part of democracy is being the
leader yourself.